on the hill today for the giants will be
their ace kevin gausman
they could start number seven guzman is
2-0 with a 2-0-4 era
40 strikeouts against 11 walks at 39 and
two-thirds you say well how does he do
it
with a fastball it'll go mid to high 90s
he can two and foreseen that pitch
fernando back in that
familiar lead-off spot that trent
grisham has been in they flip-flop
for this game today on the ground and
it'll be way over there brandon belt
to gosman who had to get over there to
the bag and he does
for the out over there and awkwardly
landed on the bag at first i think he's
okay
grisham for the year hitting 311 five
homers five doubles nine battered in a
386
on base percentage
movement inside corner just scrapes the
edge of the strike zone
trent grisham had a few words with lentz
that was a two-seam fastball had
movement coming back to the plate and
that
is what got him the call two down in the
first inning brings up manny machado
2-1 and that is sharply hit off of the
shortstop crawford into left field
hot shot off the bottom machado and he's
a board with two down here in the first
inning
this was a missile off the bat of manny
nice effort by crawford joe musgrove on
the mound today for the padres
making his seventh start of the season
second in a row versus these giants last
sunday of course against the giants
a lot of season high six run only five
were earned
his uh strikeouts is a big key to his
success this year 47 strikeouts in
34 innings and look at that minuscule
opponent's batting average at 149 for
joe musgrove
inside out swing and a ground ball to
short on the run
and not in time machado tried to get it
over there he was on the left side as
part of the shift
talkman reaching well it looked like it
was slow motion
off the bat of talkman he gets jammed
big time
this is sharply hit down to third
machado to second for one on to first
for
two double play lead single by talkman
but that does not matter
played an inning in san francisco no
score two balls two strikes
here it comes swinging there's a line
driving the right field and diving
forward for it
cronin he was 60 feet into the outfield
and he could not get a squeeze on it he
made the dive
trying to get it before it hit the grass
and it looked like it might have
skipped off his glove so belt is aboard
this top spin rider that just kind of
sunk on him at 106 miles per hour
here's longoria now there's a swing
we'll drive down the right field line
that
is a fair ball it rolls into the corner
hits off the side wall
ricochets into the first archway around
the third goes belt and
sliding into second with a double is
evan longoria
that was another fastball to the inside
part of the plate and evan longoria gave
it a beautiful
inside out kind of a stroke second and
third nobody out for the giants
on goria's seventh double of the year
and here is brandon crawford
i drive to right myers looking up
out of here he ambushed him on the first
pitch
a laser beam of a home run for brandon
crawford and the giants have a
three nothing lead well to paraphrase
the late russ hodges
i don't see how he's doing it but he's
been doing it all week and that was a
fastball on the
inner third of the plate about mid thigh
boom
down for joe musgrove slowly hit
longoria throw on the run nice play
got him longoria you could tell that he
realized the pitcher
was running and he took a little bit
more time to make the play
he charged in had to make the bare hand
pick up that was the only way he was
going to get him
and he just barely got him but he did
ready 3-2 pitch is swung on and missed
strike three wow he threw his best
splitter of the game right there
and he struck out osmer each hitter
was a battle but gusman got all three of
them 3-2
talkman swings grounds it slowly to the
right side tatis has got it in the shift
short throw is in time and that's it for
the giants here in the bottom of the
fourth inning a lead single by duggar
but he is stranded and we'll go to the
fifth in san francisco
one-two pitch to cronenworth
is wrapped into right field a base hit
the second hit
for the padres comes here in the fifth
inning with one out
it looked like he was sitting on it
there's been an e2 in this inning a wild
pitch in this
inning and it's second and third with
one out on the ground
to shortstop crawford will go to first
to get the out there but in the back
door
comes jake cronenworth with the padres
first run and it's down three to one so
it's a ground out
with an rbi for nola just playing a
little game of pepper on the infield
brandon bell now who has singled belgium
it's a high drive
deep into right field this one is on its
way
[Applause]
and the giants get that run back home
run number seven for bell
he hit that one over the 365 foot side
in right field well away from the foul
pole
curveball he took that 2-2 pitch which
was a perfect pitch
he made musgrove elevate just a little
bit and he comes right back with a
curveball
down and in at the knee two-two to
machado
that's strike three man he didn't like
strike two he likes strike three even
less
and says some stuff on the way back to
the dugout and jace tingler has been
tossed
he's coming out to protect machado
initially but then engaged in
conversation you cannot argue
balls and strikes and was immediately
ejected by
nick lance the home plate umpire and
with the pitch guy now he had a 23 pitch
fifth inning and this will be his 20th
pitch
here in the sixth inning the one-two
pitch swinging a miss he struck it out
and this time he got him to chase the
high one a 98 mile an hour fastball
up above the strike zone austin slater
up as a pinch hitter 1-1 pitch there's a
line drive base hit
along the right field line coming around
third duggar he'll score easily
going to third is rough and austin
slater delivers as a pinch hitter
and the giants add-on five to one giants
cannot tell me that there's been a
right-hander today who's gone up there
and tried to do anything but go the
opposite way slater
as a pinch hitter in the sixth inning
singled home a run
slater hits one into center field and
well grisham back
look it up over here slater
last night now this afternoon and it's
seven to one
here's austin nola nola is 0 for 3.
up the middle crawford gonna go the long
way
the ball game so the giants
they take game two of this three-game
series